white people got to start getting
together specifically around race
white accountability groups are really
helpful in terms of people whose
responsibility
it is to call me on things this is all
cultic
nonsense it's all cultic behavior and
it's infused everything
finally this brings us to the washington
post understanding your whiteness video
it is all about understanding your
whiteness and truly
this is racist crap because as you may
have noticed the notion of racial
essentialism
that your racial characteristics define
you and define your perspective is
racism
the notion that we ought to treat you as
superior or inferior in your
outlook on the world based on your race
is in fact the classical definition of
racism
but it's now anti-racism because it's
directed against destroying the
quote-unquote racist systems okay so
this comes out as a weird bunch of
gobbledygook nonsense i'm gonna try and
translate it for you here here's the
washington post lead story yesterday
again from washington post the lily
racism racialization white body
supremacy is not episodic it's
structural
remember that there were um thousands of
george floyd before the one that you saw
your bodily response to this this horror
right is not the same thing as you
dealing with the structural aspects of
business george floyd's death became a
deeply personal and racial tragedy for
many americans
for the first time white people were
becoming aware of their whiteness
and the systemic ways that white
supremacy affects all of us
white people in particular get aroused
get upset
say this is unjust this isn't right this
shouldn't happen
there's like an awakening that happens
and so part of their
racial identity development is seeing
that awakening
what they do with it is really the next
piece of it
in this episode we're tackling white
racial identity and why
understanding your whiteness is integral
to becoming self-aware
as a white person i'm nicole ellis and
this is the name pause it there for a
second
alrighty so understanding your white
identity now you may have thought to
yourself i don't really have
a white identity like for me i'd be
considered white by these folks
i'm jewish my identity is many different
things but kind of in terms of ethnicity
it's more jewish because that actually
connects to how i act in the real world
and
and honestly i don't care about
ethnicity so my jewish ethnic identity
is really only tied into the fact that
as the son of a jewish mother i am
religiously jewish right
by that law but my ethnicity really has
nothing to do with it and the idea of a
general white identity is also very
weird because the only
aspect of quote-unquote white identity
is generally in american history in
opposition to quote unquote black
identity
or asian identity or mexican identity
but the reality is
that for the vast majority of history
and including american history
people didn't see themselves in terms of
white identity
okay they saw themselves in terms of
sort of where they came from there was
irish identity there was italian
identity there was czech identity there
was jewish identity there was russian
identity
and if you go to europe today trying to
say to an italian you have white
identity they'd be like what i'm italian
what are you talking about
like brits and italians they have
different cultural heritages
because culture is not the same as
ethnicity the attempt to cudgel
everybody
who is not a person of color into the
white identitarian category is an
awkward one
and is in fact a social construction but
for these folks like nicole ellis of the
washington post it is important that you
understand your white identity what they
mean is they are going to cuddle you
into an identity where you are
responsible for all the evils of the
world
you are responsible for the george floyd
situation
here first of all when rezma menachem at
the very beginning
an author when he says at the beginning
there are thousands of george floyds you
never saw
well i mean under what time context are
we talking are we talking like
the last several hundred years because
then that's true are you talking about
like the last several years the answer
of course
is no the number of black unarmed men
killed in the united states
by cops is under 20 every single year
so no it's not thousands of people or
being treated the way that george floyd
was treated okay but again the idea is
that
pointing out that incident which again
was not even like there's still no
evidence it's amazing how this has been
promulgated there's still
no evidence that was a racist incident
it was not alleged in court it was not
allowed by the federal government it's
been ledged by no one
and yet that has become the racial
incident in america despite the fact
that there's no racial animus sought
why because it's structural you've heard
that word structural
okay the idea again is that in reality
derek chauvin isn't
really according to crt even to blame
for derek shoving's activity derek
chovin
is just an agent of the structure and
the structure is to blame
and you are both to blame for upholding
the structure and you are a symptom of
that structure because you are created
by that structure
okay let's continue with this washington
post video
says why is white racial identity
important i
am originally from a smaller
town in oklahoma whiteness was the
default
and whiteness was the comfort part of
the structure of racism
in the way that it's maintained is to
keep us from recognizing
that racism is a part of our daily lives
and so it's a longer term process of
looking at your understanding of
yourself
in the world both historically but also
contextually
the family you live in the community you
live in
and what role whiteness plays in that
so here you have a woman named kelsey
aries originally saying that whiteness
was her default and her comfort
i don't know what that's supposed to
mean other than this is her confessing
her sins in mao's style
right she didn't know she was racist but
it was her default and her comfort
she didn't even know she didn't even
know what kind of sin she was committing
but she was
by dint of just where she lived and then
you have rebecca tobarak who is one of
these authors who was speaking before
saying that you know finding your
whiteness and discovering your own sin
is a lifelong process
that sounds very much again like cultic
language it sounds like a cult
it sounds like you have to spend your
entire life cleansing yourself
of whatever the master says is your sin
you have to spend your entire it's a
lifelong process of discovering your own
whiteness
and looking within or
and what exactly are you hunting for the
answer is you're hunting for whatever i
tell you to hunt for
you're hunting for your own unconscious
racial bias that has infused the core of
your very being
the only and if you can't uncover it
it's because you're racist obviously
right this is the perfect kafka trap if
you say well i looked inside myself and
i really don't think i'm racist
ah it's because you are so infused with
your own racism you can't even recognize
your own racism
pretty incredible stuff this nonsense
continues
the more you kind of dive into that the
more i'm really realizing how deeply
rooted
racism is and to like my everyday
thought process
no matter how much you work at that
there's still even almost more work to
be done a living embodied
anti-racist culture does not exist among
white people
white people got to start getting
together specifically around race
wide accountability groups are really
helpful in terms of having a place to
process
having a group of people whose
responsibility
it is to call me on things or to
challenge me
we're unpacking wrong things that we've
been
taught in history class i realized
that i needed to go back and unpack
and reorganize everything that i had
learned because it was complete
okay stop for a second okay so the so
washington post recognizes
and they suggest you should create an
accountability group this is direct
malice crap direct mouse so over the
weekend
i was reading a book about the current
what they call third revolution in china
the xi jinping revolution
and what they've done in many of their
companies is they have these sort of
political
groups where you're supposed to get
together and this has been true for
decades really since the inception of
maoism but now it's sort of moved into
the corporate sphere over there
you're supposed to have these
accountability groups where you get
together and you confess your sins
against marxism
they would actually have maoist struggle
sessions during the time of mao where
you would do this you'd get up
and you'd confess your sins and you were
forced to do this and this has been true
in every communist country right pol pot
used to have these things where you'd
get up
and you confess your sins against
marxism and then you would be punished
for it
and then you would sit back down so they
are now suggesting
that in exactly the same fashion we have
quote unquote accountability groups
if white people get together and call
each other out on their racism
and then presumably forgive each other
and the more you confess the more
praiseworthy you are
the more you say i i this is why you see
rebecca toperak in this video
saying things like well you know you
almost never finished the work it's
almost impossible to finish the work you
can never get to the end of the work or
kelsey arias saying
i've never even discovered the the depth
of my own racism i was never able to
come up with the depth of my own racism
or at least kennedy saying i have to go
back this is where it starts to get
institutional
we have to go back and we have to see
the way we teach history and we have to
re-teach ourselves history this way
and here you start to see the creep over
from these sort of personal brow beating
and the self scourging the 12th century
styles self scourging and and maui style
struggle sessions
to now we have to teach how we how we
teach we have to change how we teach
this stuff in schools to children
okay let's continue completely through a
white lens
most of us in doing this work have
experienced this where
there's a period of deep shame for being
white and for acknowledging
the harm that our ancestors have caused
and that's
a very legitimate piece of this work and
we can't ask people of color to hold our
hands
through the shame piece that needs to
happen with other white people
when you do that for one two three four
five years right you end up with
actually a community that is aligned
with each other
in theory that sounds like a good idea
but
i guess i'm curious to hear like what
are some of the pitfalls or risks that
you run if that's the only step you take
the biggest answer is white people don't
really understand racism
and so if i'm relying on other white
people to teach me about racism that can
only go
so far i only best understand racism by
talking to people who are directly
impacted by racism from different
perspectives
so in addition to having white
accountability groups and white
accountability buddies it's also really
important to have sustained and
meaningful
relationships with people of color
okay so this is rebecca toperak and all
the rest of these people suggesting they
can't even understand racism right it's
so deeply rooted in them they feel shame
they feel shame at their own whiteness
so first of all if you feel shame
because of your race
this is racist you should not feel shame
under any circumstances because of a
condition
that you were born into that's insane
okay it's the definition of racism truly
if you feel ashamed because you were
born black we would say oh my god that's
terrible why would you feel ashamed for
being born black
but now the idea is there's something
good about feeling ashamed
for being a white person why did you do
something wrong normally shame attaches
when you do something
wrong but the idea is that by the very
color of your skin
you are complicit in this racist system
because the system benefits you even
unconsciously and so you can't even
fight racism right this goes back to the
critical race theory principles that we
were talking about
right the critical race theory
principles one of them is that white
people can't even properly understand
race
only black people and only hispanic
people and only asian people
and even there is a hierarchy there only
people who are not white can properly
understand racism so now the washington
post says you need to find a black
friend
now recognize that you are all in the
same video they're saying
that if you ask a black person to guide
you on racism this
is in and of itself racist because
you're assuming that that person
has either the wherewithal or the desire
to tell you about racism it's using that
black person
as sort of a token to lead you but you
have to find black friends because
those black friends are the only ones
who are capable of awakening you to your
own racism and to your own complicity in
the system
this is all cultic nonsense it's all
cultic
behavior and it's infused everything
continue
i don't have the ability to like
inherently name things
as upholding white supremacy or as
being racist my whiteness is going to
show up at different points in my life
and at different points in different
relationships but is it fair
or healthy to be seeking out
relationships with people just to have a
diverse network
because i feel like for people of color
you're kind of constantly
trying to gauge whether or not it's
worth it to be vulnerable or share
how someone hurt you when your white
colleagues or
co-workers or friends mess up there's a
different
cost for my friends of color to be in
relationship with me
so i think one of the things that's
really important is ongoing
being a friend on an ongoing basis for
lots of different things
not just like thinking about racism as a
part of our friendship
when there's something horrible that
happens those relationships
are number one for me to um
be there for them as them for me it's a
it's a relationship
and so it should be reciprocal but also
so that i have a broader understanding
of the world
everything i thought about how i existed
in my white body in the world was very
wrong and i needed this new
lens to see the world through so i think
that's been a big piece of my own work
incredible and nicole ellis is sitting
there but so black people shouldn't be
friends with you because then they're
gonna be used as tokens
and like well they won't be used as
tokens i mean we'll still be friends but
we'll kind of use them as tokens but
we're helping to re-examine our own
prejudices and nicole ellis is sitting
there like the judge on high
trying to judge all these white people
right i mean that's that she's there to
provide them the absolution
okay this is racist nonsense it's being
taught to your kids in school it's being
pushed by the washington post
on their front page and the washington
post now the left is angry that you
caught them
okay because here's the reality there's
push back and the pushback is incredibly
serious we're seeing a bevy of states
push actions to ban the teaching of
critical race theory in schools which is
good
okay critical race theory schools have
to decide what they teach to kids
they don't teach kids that two plus two
equals five because that's a waste of
time stupid counterproductive and
illogical you shouldn't be teaching kids
about racial essentialism you shouldn't
be teaching kids that all the systems of
power in the united states are racist
you shouldn't be teaching kids that by
dint of their very skin color they ought
to feel shame
you shouldn't teach kids false notions
of american history
because that's a garbage thing to do and
you're starting to see blowback on this
and the left which has embraced
all of this right the left loves this
stuff right joe biden's administration
agrees with this washington post video i
dare you to find a single member of the
washing
of honestly of the biden administration
who would dare to say that this video
is the pretentious crappy self-defeating
nonsense that it is you wouldn't find
one person in the entire administration
who would say that not one
so the blow and the blowback is coming
and the blowback is very very real
and the left is very upset about it it
is not a coincidence that the same day
that the washington post
ran this particular video the washington
post also ran
a very long piece being very angry that
anybody
including christopher ruffo who's one of
the people leading the charge has been
fighting back against critical race
theory
and this is precisely the point the left
has been renormalizing america by
pushing radical ideas
slowly into the mainstream by being
intransigent and very very loud
inside specific institutions okay they
push a little bit and then they push a
lot but
they continue to push and they are very
intransigent and they hope that by
bullying you into silence and feel and
making you feel shame for your own race
and making you feel shame for your own
systems
and making you feel shame for america
and they can shut you up and then take
over the institutions
and what's happening right now is that
that vast middle is saying no
all it takes to quote-unquote
re-normalize and already re-normalize
institutions is a bunch of people in the
middle saying absolutely not we're not
doing this
and this is why the left is getting
pissed because a bunch of people who are
here too for silent a bunch of people
who are very quiet up to this point
they're now standing up
and they're taking back their school
boards they're standing up and they're
retaking their legislatures they're
standing up and they're retaking
congressional seats and they're saying
no
and the left can't handle it because for
a long time twenty percent of the
country has run the other eighty percent
of the country
and now there's a vast swath in the
middle we're saying no we're not going
to do this stuff
which is phenomenal and the first step
on that
is awareness of the fact that this 20
percent of people these radicals who
have created this coalition or to push
this nonsense have started to take over
the institutions and in many cases have
already
have done that you can renormalize as
long as you have a core percentage on
the other side of 20
and the and the 60 in the middle the
unaligned
side with the 20 push back rather than
the 20 radicals who are pushing this
stuff in the first place that's how
renormalization happens and it's already
happening and it's great to watch and
the left is scared out of their wits
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight
and top of your feed